lifeguards in Mumbai aren't taking any
chances they have erected police
barricades to stop tourists from going
near the beach India's Coastal state of
Gujarat is expected to be lashed by
strong winds and heavy rains on Thursday
which means disaster in Bengali is a
tropical Cyclone that's formed over the
Arabian Sea authorities in Pakistan are
also on high alert
they've issued evacuation orders for 80
000 people from coastal towns
we got the warning about the Cyclone
from the Navy and Customs officials they
have stopped issuing fishing licenses we
have recalled all our boats and docked
them God forbid if a cyclone does come
we will also move to Safe places
for years climate scientists have been
warning that the intensity of storms in
the Arabian Sea will increase the U.N
says warmer oceans are fueling tropical
Cyclones which cause severe flooding
fishing communities in Karachi are
worried the destruction of Mangrove
forests will make things worse
I'm telling you if a cyclone hits a full
force Karachi will be destroyed within
minutes the reason for this is that we
have cut down all the mangroves how many
mangroves were here we haven't saved any
of them if the mangrove forest had still
been here today we could have been safe
two of India's largest Sports kandla and
Mundra have suspended operations and
schools have closed the region is no
stranger to storms especially during the
monsoon season
but each year the extreme weather
patterns last longer and cause more
damage
last year more than a third of Pakistan
was underwater for months entire towns
and Villages were washed away and more
than 33 million people were displaced
from their homes
still ahead on algebra